Michael big picture first of all why is
the West all of a sudden this Trio of
allies so concerned with with China and
is the threat it poses very real or not
yes I mean in a general sense I mean
China is a revisionist power meaning it
wants to change the rules there are four
big powers in the world right America
China Russia India the the big powers
for all different reasons but they
create the weather for everybody else
and two of those four powers Russia and
China are revisionists they want to
change the rules these are the rules
that have been around for 350 odd years
established by first of all the Dutch
then the British then the Americans the
maritime Nations those rules have served
everybody really very well and since
1945 those rules have been reinforced in
many many ways now Russia and China both
want to change the rules to suit
themselves so that's where the pushback
comes whether the present rules are
right or not whether people like them or
not they're the one the rules that most
most of the world lives by and so given
that those rules are now under challenge
of course the Americans and their allies
are pushing back against them and what's
happening in the Pacific is that Chinese
military development is such and the
Chinese do Bully everybody else in their
area it has created back not just in
America and Australia but in India in
the Philippines in Vietnam everybody is
now pushing back against this Chinese
assertiveness across the across the
Pacific but but to what extent would the
Chinese point on this be to say well we
don't agree with your rules and in our
own backyard we get to set them and
pushing submarines into the indo-pacific
is not something you should be doing
well they can argue that um but I mean
their own backyard is their own country
and I mean we have issues with the
behaviors xinjiang Province where there
is genocidal policies taking place and
we say well that's not acceptable we're
going to criticize it but their backyard
does not include in the current rules of
the game of the countries like Vietnam
and the Philippines and Indonesia all of
these countries are affected by What's
called the nine dash line the the
Chinese in 1952 established a line which
the the old nationalist Chinese had
talked about which basically takes all
of the South China Sea as their own and
there you can see that that's called the
first island chain that line is
something that the Chinese worry about
they say we effectively want real
control in this first island chain and
that island chain runs you see the the
gray Island there just to the uh to the
off offshore that's Taiwan so of course
that belongs to China in their View and
the nine-dash line runs all the way down
the first island chain and there's a
second island chain I mean they want not
just as it were control within the first
island chain but a second island chain
runs from Japan right down to Indonesia
and they want dominance in that part of
the Pacific that covers a lot of the
neighbors of China so that's what the
West is pushing back against and they're
saying if we want if we want Security in
the Pacific then these other countries
have got to feel that they can't be
bullied by China and and just quickly as
things stand today who does dominate
this this uh region and how much to the
the new measures announced yesterday
change things the Americans are
predominant in the region because
they've got a very strong relationship
with China with South Korea just next
door to to uh to Japan oh sorry they've
got a strong relationship and next door
South Korea and with Taiwan and
increasingly with countries like the
Philippines and Indonesia and Vietnam
although the Americans were beaten in
Vietnam in the 1960s very strong
relationship now with Vietnam so
America's policies which after all are
policies of voluntarism they're about
rules and nobody has to have the
Americans involved but they choose to
and China is challenging all of that so
the challenging American and Western
dominance in the region and the
challenge you get very very strongly